Halloween Horror Nights is the one time per year...
...when Universal Studios Hollywood transforms itself into a living horror movie.
This year, fear comes to life...
...as Halloween Horror Nights unleashes the most terrifying horror legends of all time.
An all new A Nightmare on Elm Street maze,...
...a brand-new Friday the 13th maze,...
...and our first ever 3D maze with Rob Zombie's House of 1,000 Corpses in 3D ZombieVision.
Plus, an original maze, Vampyre: Castle of the Undead...
...and back by popular demand, Saw, with new twists and traps.
Also, all new: the spine-chilling Terror Tram...
...featuring La Llorona, Chucky, and Psycho.
Yeah, really scary.
Halloween Horror Nights: what fear fears most.